one of the first responders was a
civilian who says he did a simple thing
working his way through the mangled cars
of that train daniel Cosel Minh took
these photos from the tracks minutes
before police and rescue crews arrived
the 24 year old Eagle Scout was driving
to work with his girlfriend when the
train derailed
he says his emergency response training
helped him assess victims and lead them
out of the wreckage we talked with
Konzelman last night at his family home
we were both in like our dress clothes
for work and I had a little bit of
emergency response gear like a
flashlight and some some boots so we
threw those on and ran down to the
tracks as fast as we could and nobody
was there nobody was leading or
responding to the incident I did my best
to sort of take charge of the situation
because I was up on the tracks on the
bridge I was able to just do a simple
thing and get people out of the train
cars and down to the freeway when I got
to that car that was overturned and the
people were pinned it was hard there was
a gentleman he was pinned from the waist
down
but he was so calm and he didn't look
like he was injured in that moment when
I felt super helpless I realized like I
I just want to be with this guy so I
grabbed his hand and I just talked to
him I rubbed his back I just tried to
make him as comfortable as he could be
the whole time I was praying asking the
Lord for courage and wisdom and
protection as that train was sort of
suspended above us and could have
shifted and crushed any of us how can I
help what can I do give these people
comfort what would I want somebody to do
for me if I was in that position or if
one of my brothers was in that position
you're doing it out of love for them I
think in out of love for their families
that's what gave me the motivation just
in a lot of a lot of ways not let fear
be a factor to just to just do you know
Daniel Konzelman
yes I mean no surprising that they knew
that that guy is an Eagle Scout and yeah
it shows you the kindness of strangers
at times like this thing is own life
exactly
Eagle Scouts should be very proud of him
today